la loire source d'inspiration de bien
des artistes
julien breton est nantais son truc c'est
le light painting de la peinture de
lumière une technique photographique qui
lui permet de réaliser des choses
surprenantes en bord de loire
mon nom c'est julien breton moment
d'artistes ces cas là mais je suis
artiste calme
oh
je suis passé de la calligraphie papier
à la calligraphie lumineuse au light
painting
en 2006 je me suis énormément entraîné
sur les bords de loire parce que c'était
un espace qui me permettait d'avoir une
certaine obscurité est aussi une
certaine tranquillité je passais des
soirées de 21h jusqu'à 5 heures du matin
toute la nuit sur des dunes de sable en
bord de loire pour travailler la
calligraphie répéter mes mouvements
jusqu'à obtenir la calligraphie que je
souhaitais
j'utilise des lampes que j'achète dans
le commerce
et ensuite que je commises avec du
scotch noir et la gélatine de couleur
qui va nous permettre de changer la
couleur avoir d'orange du bleu à avoir
différentes températures de couleur en
fonction du lieu
on va choisir tant de ton bras pour voir
où vers où tu votes de partir de là
ouais dif et le la naissance de décaler
un petit peu pour ouvrir le cadre par là
nous
on réalise tout mémoire directement dans
l'espace en trois dimensions si chaque
mouvement doit être répétée parfaitement
chorégraphié parfaitement positionnés
dans l'espace la calligraphie lumineuse
la porte le fait d'avoir un décor de
fond qui se propose à moi et qui du coup
se crée naturellement sens que j'ai
besoin d'intervenir plastiquement sur le
papier